Let me tell you a little secret, our master of
microscopes, James, will occasionally
just email us pictures he has taken
of the microcosmos that are just
stunning. We will get them and everyone
will fawn over them and then feel
very special that we got to see something so
amazing that brightened up our work day a little bit.
Because, as we hope you have discovered
from watching this channel, there is
beauty in the invisible, and there is joy in
letting yourself fall into it for a while.
And so we decided that we want to invite you into
that as well. We’ve put together 13 of James’
stunning images in the 2023
Journey to the Microcosmos
calendar. Each image is accompanied by a little
blurb explaining what it is you’re looking at,
and each photo showcases both James’ work as
an artist, and the beauty of the microcosmos.
Plus, you’re probably going to get a 2023
wall calendar, so why not support your
favorite microscopic YouTube channel at the same time.
You can find it at ComplexlyCalendars.com,
where some of the other shows from Complexly,
the company that produces this show,
also have calendars available. There's SciShow
and SciShow Space, Bizarre Beasts and Eons.
Or if you don't want to type all that
stuff out you can can just click the link
in the description. Or the pinned comment.
Or anywhere else we could find to put it.
We’re really excited to share the
microcosmos with you in all the ways that we do,
but we only made a pretty limited number of these,
so we think they might sell out pretty fast.
To get yours, just go to complexlycalendars.com
and again, the link is, somewhere nearby